Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P
here is I'm trying to understand this voicemail,
so hopefully you can help me. I believe that this
is a conservative Hispanic caller who says white
progressives are the worst. And I think he's
talking about me even though I'm Hispanic.
Speaker 4: I think that as a Hispanic
white progressives are the most racist.
I think white progressives need to
stop telling we Hispanics or people in color in
general of what to think. This is just another
form of slavery that you're trying to here.
Speaker 1: So let me I'm I am going to say an
example where I agree with this caller. Okay. But
then most of this voicemail is a dumpster fire.
One of the things I don't like is something that
has been imposed by mostly white progressives and
that is Latin X rather than Latino Latina, Latin
X. I am a progressive and I am also Hispanic and I
don't like it. I don't know any actual Hispanic
people who use that. And so I've said before,
Latin X did not arise, uh, naturally from within
the community. It was sort of like imposed by
mostly white progressives. And that one thing I am
against. But most of this voice mail is bonkers.
Speaker 4: You're not only trying to tell us
what to think, but how to think. I'm sorry.
Homosexuality is wrong. Abortion is wrong.
Speaker 1: So this is a conservative
Hispanic individual.
Speaker 4: So why don't you,
white progressives just simply leave us alone
and stop brainwashing our people? Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, listen, there
is a large por I mean, it should be said
that along with Jewish folks overall,
Hispanic Americans are quite progressive.
That's actually that that's the truth of the
matter. And so don't blame white progressives
for Hispanic voters being in favor of legal
abortion and being in favor of gay marriage.
Most of these positions we came to on our own.
So kind of a weird caller, pretty unhinged with
like one tiny little fraction of a grain of truth
there. We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the passing of the last
Soviet leader, Gorbachev, Mikhail Gorbachev,
who passed away at age 91. We are going to
talk about California fast food workers very
close to winning some historic protections. And
we will talk about the incredible viral video
of a black pastor watering his neighbor's
flowers. And the police show up. And it is crazy,
crazy video. All of those stories and more when I
am joined by producer Pat on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: The bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, you can judge for
yourselves when you sign up at join dot
mint.com. You can use the coupon code,
big voting 22 to get a discount.
And I will see you that.